by this time i'm sure that you were all
fully aware of the mandates that joe
biden put on small businesses across the
country if you have more than 100
employees you are required to either
test all of your employees who are not
vaccinated which will cost every company
thousand dollars a month or
you have to mandate that they are all
vaccinated and if you do not do so then
you could end up with a 14 000
fine per violation now apparently
however that mandate isn't required for
everybody
congress
does not have to adhere to that mandate
and neither does the usps uh albeit for
different reasons but first let's go
ahead and address congress it's actually
not only congress that doesn't have to
adhere to that mandate it's also the
judicial branch and all of their staff
now if biden and the cdc and other
people claim that this is a a
a pandemic of the unvaccinated they
blame unvaccinated people regularly
for why the pandemic has not quote
ceased uh they also say that we should
have unwavering confidence
within the
vaccines
and
once again we are seeing another step in
the direction of pushing people away
from the vaccines that they believe can
solve this pandemic
now i'm sure that they have a good
reason
for why
they don't have to be vaccinated right
they have a good reason for why they can
ignore the mandates right
well nancy pelosi's reason is that you
know
every congress member has a right to
privacy in fact even right now
the only way that they determine whether
or not someone is actually vaccinated is
according to the honor system in
congress
80 percent of republicans actually don't
want to tell whether or not they're
vaccinated and even if the democrats
are quote-unquote vaccinated it is only
based off of a system in which they can
tell you they are vaccinated
even though they may not be without
incurring any type of penal action if
they are in fact lying because we would
never know
so
what exactly
is going on here
how can you justify potentially putting
small businesses in a position where
they either require everyone to get
vaccinated
they spend thousands of dollars in tests
because they don't want to force
everybody to get vaccinated but they
also don't want their employees to leave
or they fire people to put them under
the 100 employee mark while
simultaneously allowing the same
congress dominated by democrats telling
the world they must get vaccinated
not requiring them to get vaccinated
how is that building up
any type of credibility any confidence
or legitimacy in the vaccine that you
are pushing literally forcing on the
entire country to the point where you
could doom the economy because of it
because 70 of all workers said that they
will quit their job if they are required
to get a vaccine
what is the goal here
as a matter of fact how can anyone trust
anything that is coming out of your
mouth when once again we see another
inconsistency
by the federal government when it comes
to the way the executive in the judicial
branch is handling this covet pandemic
if you want people to feel confident
enough to get this vaccine either the
pfizer booster or the modern vaccine if
that's what you really want
then maybe you should practice some sort
of consistency because what it looks
like to me is that the reason
you don't want congress to get the to to
be mandated to take the vaccines because
congress has a little bit of a vaccine
hesitancy but also has the power to
fight back if they do not want to have
the mandate forced upon them
in addition to that the executive branch
doesn't have the power to enforce it on
uh congress because
that's congress's so uh sole
responsibility
on the other side of that fence you have
the usps who has the power to shut down
all the mail in the in the nation
and in places around the country police
departments even are being exempt from
the mandates so what it seems like to me
is that
the people who have the power to fight
back against the mandates
those are the ones the mandates that
apply to
so why is it that you are only
pushing the mandates on those who can't
fight back and when is that ever voted
well for the people of the united states
you